Generally worked on problems by looking
at how can we solve the problem,
but that's very much a fixed mindset.
You know,
here's the problem and what can we do to
solve it and technology advances in
technology have enabled us to do that
and is that important?
Of course it is.
It's necessary,
but it's not sufficient.
So how can we solve problems in an
enduring way,
in an equitable way,
in a way where nobody really loses
because too often we look at an issue
from a scarcity mindset,
but frankly we have an abundant planet
and we have people with so much
creativity.
Can we engage that way differently?
So that's what this journey is about.
Awakening the space within me and within
everybody else and it's about awakening
and articulating what we see through our
pattern mind.
And third,
it's about solving problems through that
space.
It's not about fixing it.
And what's amazing is that people have
innate attributes worldwide and
neuroscience and recent research shows
that what we can see is that human
beings have a sense of self,
their own self worth,
which we often,
you know,
talk about as dignity.
So they have a sense of self worldwide.
It doesn't matter whether we are rich,
we are poor,
whether we follow any faith or whether
we
vote for a particular political party.
This transcends all those divides,
the social isms that we've created.
So basically the sense of self worth
exists and the sense of fairness exists
worldwide.
And so very often people ask me,
what is it that there's so much inequity
in the world and you say that we have an
innate sense of fairness.
In fact,
Oxfam did a study in the US and they
found that 92 percent of people actually
believe that fairness is important.
How great is that?
So then people say,
how come there's so much inequity?
I think a lot of the inequities stems
from our understanding of what we need.
Much of that is promoted through
creating demand for things we actually
don't need to a consumerism that's
extremely materialistic and this work is
about touching that space.
And this work is also about the third
attribute that is compassion.
What we know now is that people are not
only functioning from their emotional
state.
What you know are neuroscientists are
physician will call our limbic system
and our emotional reactions.
Not that emotion is not important,
it's important,
but we have a higher consciousness and
activating that consciousness that
exists in everyone everywhere and I can
give you many,
many stories from around the world about
that.
When we activate that space of our
higher consciousness,
we bring to bear our innate sense of
self,
our sense of fairness,
our compassion.
So compassion.
There's a lovely Sanskrit.
Sanskrit is a based language of of India
and a Sanskrit word Karuna.
Karuna means my,
my universal heart of love has broken
open and I'm called to act.
I cannot just bossed by what's not
working and say,
well,
it doesn't serve my personal interest in
or I'm called to act.
So for me,
tapping into this spaces worldwide,
which is our inner capacity,
our sense of self,
our sense of fairness,
our knowing of compassion.
This has been the way we've created
change worldwide and it's worked.
We have results in every sector.